el ataque se ha producido contra una
escuela de arte en mariupol informa el
alcalde que abrían hasta 400 personas en
los refugios antiaéreos e intentando
protegerse precisamente de eso de las
bombas mariupol es una ciudad portuaria
del sur de ucrania que lleva tres
semanas siendo fuertemente atacada por
el ejército ruso y dos semanas con un
cerco que está asfixiando a la población
hay problemas de acceso a la comida la
gran mayoría de la ciudad está
completamente bombardeada y la comunidad
internacional que ha pedido en varias
ocasiones a vladimir putin que deje
salir a esos ciudadanos con seguridad
pero de momento no hay corredores
humanitarios seguros para los ciudadanos
que están atrapados en mariupol el
propio alcalde de mariupol informaba en
las últimas horas que el ejército ruso
está teniendo cierta ventaja en el
control de la ciudad y eso supondría que
ucrania perdería el control de acceso al
mar azov en el resto del país la guerra
continúa las sirenas se empiezan a sonar
en prácticamente todas las ciudades
también en leópolis donde nos
encontramos estaremos muy accesos de
esos corredores humanitarios en las
ciudades cercadas y también de la
situación de todas esas personas
atrapadas en la escuela de arte en
maribor